the world is coming undone Imperial
flags rain across the galaxy
I feel very very proud you know to be in
a business for so many years you know
having you know Asian has proven
themselves who as good as anybody else
my character is very connected to the
force and in fact his lines is always
surrounded by connecting with the force
the force the review I'm before I just a
lot of research you know I did a little
research and how to play a very fun not
just a very typical blind person he's a
blind warrior that lives in a Star Wars
universe so I was intended to create
this character very unique and special
in my films nowadays no matter what what
films that I mean you know I think the
influences is automatic if I'm Donnie
obviously you're gonna see a lot of
Donnie in its characteristic in in any
role that I play not just this role you
see that when I'm fighting is part of me
a time I didn't really want to leave my
home and my children's had a lot to deal
with it because I asked them would you
like to see a father in Star War and of
course the answer was yes the past
Hollywood Halloween we want to do a Star
War theme was my wife's idea and we
asked this need to to help me and they
were very generous and then sent me the
exact fabrics from my outfits sent over
to Hong Kong and had my Hong Kong team
to create the exact outfit for the past
Halloween and then I posted up in this
room and my daughter was the
stormtrooper I don't believe it was
creative especially for me they were
looking for a character like that and I
believe that was the reason why they
call me
well I think Church if you give him a
lifesaver and take on Darth Vader the
producer didn't give me the bill a safe
I think that stormtroopers you know for
me when you could fight 10g get by 20
and I in that world